[Musique]
bonjour les magiciels bonjour tous alors
je vais vous présenter chacune Virginie
albaounier vous êtes d'abord prof de de
Yata yataoga at at yoga ouioga ça ser
moins bien ATA yoga c'est quoi le hata
yoga le yoga je vois à peu près le hata
yoga c'est un yoga traditionnel indien
c'est le le yoga traditionnel d'origine
on va dire et ce n'est pas que une
pratique physique c'est aussi une
pratique spirituelle voilà donc a huit
pas dans le yoga et la pratique des Asan
c'est-à-dire les postures que nous
connaissons ce n'est que un seul pas
parmi les huit autres pas donc le ATA
yoga on travaille les h pas du yoga les
h pas du yoga et et vous êtes également
adjointe au maire de villan en charge de
la culture et oui la culture l'animation
de la ville et aussi la vie associative
à côté de vous nia CREPS bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes directrice des opération
chez Tessi oui Tessi c'est quoi en un
mot alors Tess alors Tess est un groupe
qui offre des prestations externalisées
qu'on appelle Business Process
Outsourcing et moi je suis plus
particulièrement en charge des
solutions pour la BU chèque donc on
offre des logiciels et des prestations
pour les traitements bancaires pour tous
les grands groupes financiersord parfait
et Rebecca Rimi bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes juriste vous êtes comédienne
oui tout à fait et et et vous allez
participer toutes les TR du 8 au 15
novembre au trek des Gazelles c'est
trking g ça sappelle et c'est c'est dans
le Sud marocain dans le désert marocain
c'est ça alors voilà j'ai dit j'ai dit
reboui vous êtes vous êtes juriste vous
êtes
comédienne mais voilà vous vous souffrez
aussi de d'une maladie hein tout à fait
qui s'appelle le spinaabifida voilà
voilà c'est ma maladie de base parce que
comme moi je fais jamais les choses à
moitié j'en ai développé d'autes
derrière exactement on va pas ça entir
petitte chose et non et le spin FIDA
fait fait que euh bah vos muscles euh
enfin vous m postérieur euh postérieur
comment on dit ça non B c'est le musc
des membres inférieurs en fait c'est une
mauvaise oui des jambes c'est une
mauvaise fermeture du tube neural qui
arrive à la 3è semaine de conception et
si une atteint de la moelle épinière en
tout cas chez moi c'est en voie en voie
basse et donc ça atteint mes membres
inférieurs donc je ne sens pas mes
jambes euh j'ai besoin de mes yeux pour
marcher parce que je ne sens pas le sol
et aujourd'hui je suis appareillé avec
des orthèses je l'ai pas toujours été
mais en grandissant ça dégénère et
aujourd'hui jeis votre jambes ne vous
soutiennent plus c'est ça non voilà je
je m'effondre sur moi-même je n'ai pas
les muscle qu'il faut pour me tenir
droite en équilibre est-ce que c'est
bien malin d'aller marcher 20 20 20 K
par jour pendant 4 jours je suis pas sûr
mais je suis une femme de défi au 15
novembre non c'est ça c'est le défi
formidable que vous êtes lancé toutes
les
trois c'est c'est vous qui avait
rencontré je crois Rebecca hein ouais en
fait c'est c'est ça l'histoire Rebecca
en tant que adjoint auomè Rebecca avait
besoin pour lancer son spectacle de de
répéter et avait une salle avait besoin
d'une salle pour répéter en vrai en
nature donc on elle est venue vers nous
et on a trouvé le projet sympa et comme
c'était la première fois qu'on pouvait
ouvrir une résidence à Villain on a on a
ouvert la la salle des fêtes à Rebecca
pour qu'elle puisse répéter pour ses
répétition voilà donc du coup elle a
fait son premier spectacle la la général
à Villen dans ah bah oui quand même
avant d'aller au théâtre le bout c'est
ça oui à Paris et chose exceptionn je
joue samedi soir prochain dans la
commune d'eville dans 78 le 14 octobre à
20h donc si les gens ont envie de venir
c'est avec plaisirou ok oui c'est c'est
un spectacle que vous jouez à Paris deux
fois par mois c'est ça oui et et sinon
de j'ai quand une commune veut m'acheter
mon spectacle ben j'y vais avec plaisir
alors faut lancer des app par il
s'appelle Wonder Life et ça raconte quoi
c'est l'histoire de ma vie avec humour
avec sarcasme je me moque de moi-même du
handicap des cancers chimio voilà je je
ris de mon parcours parce que je suis
surtout pas dans le Patos et ça faisait
longtemps que vous aviez envie de monter
sur scène c'était unevie moi je voulais
être soit comédienne soit médecin j'ai
raté médecine je suis comédienne mais je
suis devenue avocate aussi vous avocate
voilà vousz pas c'est pas queur raté non
non pas du tout mais cela dit entre les
avocats et les les com a pas il y a pas
de grand
différ non c'est bien et et et et donc
ça vous jouez oui au le bout deux fois
par mois et puis à cevill le
14ob c'est samedi hein c'est samedi
prochain voilà dans 5 jours voilà et
donc vous avez rencontré
Rebecca mais quand est-ce qu' est venue
l'idée d'aller participer à strekin des
Gazelles en fait elle m'en a parlé très
très vite parce que elle a plusieurs
rêves et plusieurs choses en route et
comme moi je suis prof de yoga et
également navigatrice
équipière j'arrive à à savoir comment
naviguer même à la boussole donc quand
on en a parlé toutes les deux et du coup
son projet m'a beaucoup parlé et puis
elle elle dégage une énergie incroyable
incroable donc elle m'a embarqué on va
dire dans ce projet de navigation alors
c'est pas vraiment une navigation c'est
on sera dans le désert mais on va on va
on va donc utiliser boussole et carartte
et puis bon voilà relever le défi de
marcher dans ces conditions 20 20 km par
jour pendant 4 jours voilà fait partie
des gens qui vous donnent du peps quoi
oui et puis l'occasion aussi de l'Acer
je parle pas trop trop fort parce
qu'elle est
là voilà un coach fait du yoga avec moi
aussi donc donc moi je suis à Villen mon
je développe le yoga à Villain sur scène
et à poissi donc mes cours sont pleins
sur vilain sauf le mardi
et j'ai encore de la place pour prendre
des personnes à poissi chez chez EOS la
maison du bien-être à poissi c'est un
bel un bel endroit et alors Nadia Nadia
arrive quand sur ce projet Nadia arrive
avec avec Tessie
justementad arvead arrive seul d'abord
non Nadia arrive d'abord parce que c'est
la voisine de de Virginie ouais et ami
aussi quand même c'est pas si petit
c'est pas si petit que vous connaissez
tous alors on est carrément dans le même
immeuble on est carrément sur le même
palier voilà voilà elle fait du bruit
non elle est pas non c'est pas même pas
même pas on a on a vu rapidement qu'on
avait des valeurs communes et et
effectivement elle m'a parlé d'un projet
alors très
tardivement je pense que c'était en
février mars de cette année euh
et voilà elle m'a parlé du projet elle
m'a dit que il y avait une place de de
libre dans cette dans cette aventure un
peu folle elle m'a parlé de Rebecca on
s'est rencontré dans les dans les oui
tout à fait tout à fait vous avez le
dossard 27 26 26 26 et alors donc voilà
vous rencontrez tous les trois toutes
les trois pardon et et vous dites on va
créer cette association qui s'appelle
les magiciales oui parce qu'en fait la
l'avantage d'être sous forme associative
ça nous permet d'avoir des sponsors ça
nous permet de gérer également tout
notre travail c'est assez intense quand
même d'organiser ce trekah il faut
l'organiser le budget c'est un peu à peu
près 17500 € on était sur un budget
voilà comme ça parce qu'il faut équiper
beaucoup Rebecca ça c'est vraiment pas
habituel he d'aller dans le désert avec
ses orthèses et il lui faut du matériel
qui soit euh chaussur des voilà vraiment
valable et puis nous aussi il faut pas
nous oublier parce que nous on est
aidente entre guillemets les aidant
c'est très important on vaarler au niau
duè prenant c'est très oui chronophage
c'est chronophage et puis les aidents
aussi c'est vrai c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est quelque chose dont on parle assez
peu on parle bien sûr c'est bien des des
des personnes en situation de handicap
on oublie parfois qu'ils ont besoin des
dents et que les aents sont font un
travail absolument formidable dans
l'ombre et ex et c'est bien de les
mettre de mettre en oui oui parce qu'on
on s'en rend compte au quotidien quand
on on travaille avec Rebecca quand on
est amis hein donc quand on vit ensemble
entre guillemets on se rend compte que
Ben son quotidien n'est pas évident et à
nous aussi de découvrir comment une
personne handicapée vit au quotidien
donc on apprend des deux côtés en fait
hein c'est très important c'est vraiment
un un un travail d'équipe oui hein je
dirais que voilà vous êtes vous êtes
vous êtes forte à tr un peu moins forte
si vous étiez chacun de votre côté ah
bah clairement si elle n'était pas là je
ne pourrais pas faire ce track c'est
évident vous vous êtes entraîné
évidemment on s'entraîne vous entraînez
encore ou évidemment parce que c'est et
elle me pousse et je les énerve parfois
c'est-à-dire bah parce que c'est pas
c'est pas évident c'est on n pas le même
rythme de marche moi je moi pour moi dès
que je fais un petit pas je vais très
très vite j'ai l'impression d'aller très
vite alors que pour les fillees c'est
bon bah c'est c'est plus lent quoi mais
je m'en rends pas compte et et et
comment
vous imaginez comme ça désert marocain
peut-être avec de la chaleur m si au
mois de novembrefin il est prévu entre 0
et 30°g donc on la nuit plus plus vous
vous dormez comment d'ailleurs il y a un
BiVO installé par l'organisateur Mayanga
ouais
oui vous am faire 20 km
oui moi je moi je m'imagine très bien le
faire parce que je connais les grands
espaces pour avoir traversé deux fois
les océans l'Atlantique et et et
l'Indien donc en équipage he pas toute
seule mais les grands espaces ça me
plaît énormément donc ça fait aussi
partie du du défi mais se retrouver dans
Nadia aussi he alors oui mais il va y
avoir moi je suis un petit peu je suis
un peu leur principe de réalité hein je
voilà je suis avec deux rêveuses
et et et j'amène ma petite touche ma
petite touche de de gestion de projets
de gestion du risque
et et on se prépare et après une fois
qu'on sera là-bas par contre on va se
laisser porter on va on va être voilà on
va fautpr avant quoi après le reste
c'est
c'est g après faudra s'adapter après
après il y aura
deimprévisible ça va être dur moi je
sais que il est probable que j'en pleure
sur place parce que monter des dunes
c'est c'est très compliqué c'est ça
c'est pas c'est pas du
plat du Caou il y a en et puis euh voilà
je suis la première personne en
situation de handicap à faire ce
tracking a pas d'utre non jamais non
mais moi je voulais faire le rally des
Gazelles en voiture mais c'était pas
possible parce que moi je conduis à la
main donc c'était vraiment une
organisation trop lourde et quand j'ai
entendu qu'il parlait de qu' faisait une
s un pion je me suis dit bah voilà ma
voiture c'est mes jambes vous dites i il
y a jamais eu de de de personnes en
situation de handicap qui l'ont fait euh
l'organisation vous a pas dit mais non
alors récemment fille le médecin m'a
appelé
de oui oui parce que moi je suis suivie
dans le pôle parasport paralympique de
Garche oui absolument euh et ils m'ont
appelé en disant qu'ils voulait parler à
mon équipe médicale mais bon ça fait
presque un an et demi 2 ans qu'on qu'on
se prépare et le médecin ne me connaît
pas mais moi je me connais je sais ce
dont je suis capable j'ai un mental en
affier vous avez vu les médecins qui
vous suivent aussi je oui tout le monde
me suit et puis j'ai des orthèses en
béton donc j'ai j'ai en carbone plutôt
carbone carb temp onavance
plus ça fait 2 ans que
s il savent très bien et puis bon le
tracking existe à pied que depuis 2021
donc c'est la 3è édition c'est assez
récent donc on peut se permettre aussi
d'essayer des choses je pense que vous
vous avez parlé avec des gens qui l'ont
déjà fait oui oui oui oui on a un
weekend de navigation on partage
également avec d'autres équipires un
entraînement sur le la boussole la
navigation à la carte la boussole V dire
un mot de vos sponsor peut-être ah oui
ah Mo alors je c'est dire tout ce qui
tout ce qui le Frix alors non
oui mais ça fait partie ça il en faut he
il
faut donc donc effectivement le le notre
sponsor principal c'est Tess
euh ma présidente a eu l'honneur de me
faire
confiance en premier pour pour financer
tous les frais d'inscription et
euh on on on a grâce à ça ça pu avancer
un peu plus sereinement dans la
recherche
des d'autres sponsors Rebecca s'est
occupé s'est occupé un peu plus
particulièrement de la suite donc voilà
on on a essayé donc c'est bon là vous
avez les sponsors qui qui vous fut ben
alors il y a Tessi en sponsor principal
il y a de C groupes de C finances il y a
AGK et il y a podo concept qui est aussi
une entreprise qui m'a fourni des des
chaussures et en terme de matériel il y
a autoboc qui m'a fabriqué mes orortèses
en carbone et Crédit Mutuel bien sûr
bien sûr créit m de notre de
l'association oui est-ce que vous
pourrez nous faire des petites images
avec plaisir oui vous n Les envoyez au
jour le jour des grand plaisir alors on
n pas le droit au téléphone pendant sur
place on est en digital dtox parce qu'on
veut aussi faire un un J pour la planète
on va ramasser le plastique dans le
désert on est des walking cleaners et et
pas de téléphone du tout bon il y a un
lien on pourra envoyer chaque jour on
pourra envoyer chaque jour des des
textes en tout cas ben Virginie
Nadia je sais pas ce qu'il fa vous dire
mais embarquz avec nous vous pourrez
faire des images ah bah
oui mais moi je me suis pas entraîné
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un de j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un qui va vous suivre merci bravo
hein comp de tout façon vous reviendrez
évidemment après mais même pendant si
voà on peut s'appeler he ave plaisir le
soir vous avez le droit au téléphone
quand même télé JIS vous pourrez nous
suivre vous pourrez nous suivre
via le le site Internet et vous pourrez
suivre ben nos aventures et nos photos
euh par la team 26 et vous pourrez bien
évidemment nous envoyer des
encouragements et team 26 c'est le
numéro de l'équipe bravo bravo bravo en
tout cas à vous et puis voilà on est
derrière vous quoi c'estciatrice merci
patri
[Musique]
merci